hey what's up mkbhd here and i think
it's safe to say we're about to be right
back in the thick of it smartphone
season is about to be upon us and what
better way to kick that off than with
a folding phone well it's a pair of
folding phones actually we have this new
samsung galaxy z fold 3 that i have a
lot of thoughts about that i was really
curious about after such a big
improvement from the last fold but also
there's a new z flip announced alongside
it that i also got to play with and
honestly if i'm only able to recommend
one of these to a regular person it's
probably the flip and it's much more
pocketable design and really nice
refinement with the outside cover screen
so check out that video it's going to
drop at the same time as this one i'll
link it below the like button but this
is the one i'm more into so this is the
one i'm more likely to use it's the
z-fold three and holding it for the
first time it does look and feel very
similar to the fold too we've seen this
look before but there's some pretty
noteworthy improvements here with a
bunch of small changes that kind of add
up to being worth a new generation so
you've probably already seen the new
camera bump it's smaller than that huge
square from last time and we'll get to
those cameras in a second but everything
everything is just a little tighter and
a little more well put together here new
gorilla glass victus on the front the
whole phone is about two millimeters
thinner and it's slightly lighter than
last year as well and the hinge the most
important part is even more tucked into
the side of the phone it doesn't stick
out as much so the whole phone along
with the weight of the hinge has this
feeling of being very firmly
well put together and it's just very
satisfying feeling it's so well put
together in fact that it's actually i
was surprised to learn it has an ipx8
water resistance rating
which is pretty intense that means it
can survive water from all directions
and can actually be immersed in water
which i already know means someone's
gonna do an underwater test with it and
i'll probably watch but that's a pretty
big step for a folding phone isn't it
now importantly that's ipx8 not ip68 so
the x means it wasn't tested for like
fine granular particles solid particles
so it's not dust resistant and that
actually makes a lot of sense that's
been the nemesis of these hinges just
little tiny grains little particles
getting into the hinge and eventually
ending up under the screen but the fact
that it's so watertight that they can
actually certify it for water resistance
is pretty impressive to me i'm pretty
sure that's the first folding phone that
we've seen the first new folding screen
type phone that's water resistant then
another great touch is the cover screen
that's on the outside which is almost
exactly the same size and resolution is
now 120 hertz also to match the inside
screen that i love last year on the fold
2 i never really got over the fact that
the 60 hertz outside screen felt worse
than the 120 hertz inside screen it made
me want to use it less but now it just
kind of feels like a really tall candy
bar shaped
normal phone with high refresh rate and
everything but let's talk about that big
inside screen shall we because this is
where we have the most changes same size
same bezels and 120 hertz refresh rate
same dust caps at the top and the bottom
but you notice anything
missing from the inside screen see last
year there was a hole punch camera at
the top in the middle of the right hand
side and if you're looking up there yeah
this year that selfie camera has moved
to behind the display oh yeah so fold
three has an under display selfie camera
inside of a folding display so i've made
an entire video just all about this
camera behind the display tech boom i'll
also link it below like button if you
want to watch that video but if you do
check it out it is a really curious
new technology it's a first generation
thing
and it definitely has some quirks and
some weird things about it which is why
i was kind of surprised actually to see
it in you know such a premium
high-end expensive samsung device but
it's here like it's definitely not
invisible by any means you can clearly
see it whenever you look for it and it
exhibits this pixelation through the
gaps in the pixels that i talked about
in that full video it's got like this
octagon shape of pixels and everything
that passes through that octagon gets
really pixelated especially when it's
bright colors and whites and especially
when it's off axis and most interesting
of all the actual quality of these other
first generation selfie cameras i looked
at
are not great it would look really hazy
in the viewfinder and then once you snap
the photo it literally runs a defogging
algorithm to sharpen up and clean up the
picture and i could actually see that
same thing happening here when i took
selfies on the fold three
it's a little hazy in the viewfinder but
then you snap the picture and then you
look at the picture fast enough you can
literally see that processing snap the
contrast in get rid of that haze
but it's still not that great of a
picture so this it's interesting that it
is i mean i'm excited to get my hands on
this phone longer term for the full
review but also to see what kind of
photo quality and video quality that
this actually produces to see how much
worse it actually is than the uh hole
punch camera that came before it
but yeah i think if you ask samsung why
they did this
i think their logic would be that this
is the least important or least used
selfie camera on the fold like you
already have on the new fold you'll have
a selfie hole punch camera on the cover
display and then if you really want a
high quality selfie well you can open it
up and point those cameras at yourself
and use the viewfinder
as a nice selfie shot so this inside
selfie camera
it's not really used all that much maybe
for video calls sometimes they're just a
very quick convenient thing
um so they figured this was samsung's
place to take a little bit of a risk
with some bleeding edge tech to give us
the full corner to corner expansive
inside screen we've wanted since the
beginning sure you can still see the
camera sometimes and it's not perfect
but hey it is better technically than a
hole punch but my favorite inside screen
improvement here is that the foldable
glass protective film is 80 percent more
durable against scratch resistance
meaning they've finally made the fold s
pen compatible now this is all great and
we love the headlines obviously this is
very exciting for people who wanted the
bigger canvas for the note taking and
all that but
this definitely comes with an asterisk
that i think we should consider okay not
to pour water on this fire or whatever
but think about it yes the fold is going
to be clearly great for note-taking
sketching maybe it's just straight up
just as good as the note at everything
it did it's got all the same s-pen
features and it's a super responsive 120
hertz panel all that is great but this
is like a special case of an s pen for
this phone okay first of all you need
literally a special s pen it's a new one
called the s pen fold edition and it
looks like a normal s pen but it has a
softer retractable tip so you can't
apply too much pressure that could still
damage the screen and it's of course
still an optional accessory so you also
need to buy an optional case to carry it
around with the fold unless you want to
have them both loose in your pocket
and other styluses
generally aren't going to work i mean
there are some big soft tip styluses if
you just want to replace your finger as
an input device but most pens for
writing and sketching and all that good
stuff are not soft tipped they're not
retractable tipped so i even got a
warning on the screen that says only use
s pens designed for your galaxy fold all
their s pens or other styluses for that
matter may damage the screen which
brings me to the only other option for
this phone which is a brand new much
bigger s pen pro
that has to be set to z fold mode which
is literally a physical switch on top of
the pen that makes the tip retract more
easily and with less pressure but that's
it now the s-pen pro it actually is
pretty cool and unlike the fold edition
it is active it's got a battery it
charges via usb type-c but it also has
on-board memory so you can copy and
paste stuff between different samsung
devices like if you have a samsung
tablet or a laptop
that sounds super cool but this is all
specialized workarounds to loop in the
galaxy fold into the s pen world so at
the end of the day if you've got to go
the extra mile to buy the s pen and buy
the case to carry it around in well then
you can do all that and you can bring
the s pen into your life but i guess
what i'm trying to say is i think
samsung should keep around the galaxy
note uh fold has a new set of triple
cameras like i mentioned an ultra wide a
standard and a 2x telephoto and a flash
right in line with the tamed down stuff
we usually see here in the fold and i
think they'll probably hold up in the
full review but we'll see and there's a
bunch of pretty sweet new software
features that make this phone even more
of a multitasking monster i already
always felt like super productive
anytime i use the fold and now there's a
new lab section in the settings where
you can like force every app to work in
multitasking for custom aspect ratios
and my favorite tweak those slide over
apps from the side you can now
permanently pin over to the right hand
side of the phone like a dock
like just straight up like a dock like a
desktop operating system and so then
your shortcuts just live over there all
the time kind of like the dock in mac os
10 or in windows it can shuffle around
your most recent apps it's really useful
for copying and pasting between apps or
moving back and forth between things
hopping your app drawer anytime from
over there
unpin it anytime you want to
very nice very nice oh i just realized i
haven't told you guys the specs yet um
snapdragon 8 and 12 gigs of ram in every
module starts at 256 gigs there's also a
half terabyte version
and 4 400 milliamp hour battery which is
technically a little smaller than last
year's 4500 but the phone is just a
little bit more compact a little thinner
and then three colors there's the silver
you just saw most of my hands on time
with but there's also a black and a
phantom green and that is a nice green
i'm kind of into that more than i expect
it to be but yeah would you this is my
question to you
just from the first impressions now that
you've seen it it's official would you
pick up this phone for 1
800
because that's how much it's going to
cost it's a little less than before but
that's the starting price for the 256
gig z-fold three
and like i said i still think among
these two new folding phones they've
announced the flip which starts at 9.99
still expensive but that's like
more of a
reasonable phone to recommend to more
people i think so if you want to check
over on that video for my thoughts on it
definitely do that but i'm curious if
you guys would be into 1800 bucks for
the newest highest end most premium
well-built folding phone i've ever seen
super interested
either way
thanks for watching subscribe if you
haven't already and i'll catch you guys
the next one
peace